I'm cure extensive Miss America 2015 and
my favorite movie is clueless clueless
is about a young woman who I think in
the beginning her concerns are a little
bit shallow you know she's concerned
about what she's wearing or about what
the boy banks and of course in the
beginning she's good as ever and she is
feisty she's confident she knows what
she wants in life kind of until she
starts learning about herself and it's
pointed out to her that she's a little
self-centered if I throughout the movie
she learns more and more about giving
back to her community and opening
herself up to others my dad and I was
little he would compare me to share so
I'd go dad as a flick shares dad he's a
big lawyer and share is so determined to
help and to be a part of all that and
the same thing with my dad when I was
younger I would say dad please take me
to work dad please you know I want to be
a part of all this I want to see what
you're doing shares dad and my dad would
probably be best friends did you get
your report card yeah not toast how'd
you do I totally choked my father was
gonna go ballistic on me he has
expectations of her he goes she I get in
here these grades are ridiculous and my
dad is the exact same way when I was in
high school I Kyra what is this see what
does this be it had to be an A he's very
very strict about those things and even
though pageants were definitely not in
his wheelhouse he supported my pursuing
the dream of Miss America no matter what
he was on my side and my number one
cheerleader share grows as a person
understands that the relationships you
have with others are things in life that
are valuable as opposed to material
possessions which she has plenty of but
those relationships are what really
matter in what count movies definitely
have the power to bring people together
whether it's a silly movie or a dramatic
movie or a scary movie there's something
that we all can recognize that we've
and here as well
I'm Kuric Sansa Miss America 2015 and I
love movies
you
you